[Music]
Scott and Penelope Disick serving some
serious blue steel I don't think
anybody's blue steel is better than
Derek's Blue Steel
but inspired by a classic Zoolander
moment
excuse me bro
you're excused
and I'm not your bra for The Tick Tock
Trend the scene is mashed up with Nelly
furtado's 2006 hit promiscuous
[Music]
and the result is comedy gold
excuse me
you're excused
[Music]
but p and Scott aren't the only family
members giving it their Spin and Kylie
Jenner and her BFF stassi went to work
on Christmas Eve
excuse me
you're excused
[Music]
but of course it's not the famous fam's
first Crossover with the Zoolander
Universe not to name drop but I'm pretty
good friends with his sister Kim
Kardashian
back to Penelope fans know she's a
Tick-Tock Pro
I mean it's a beautiful thing not only
does p tackle the trends she's also down
to poke fun at her famous family I think
you have to have a sense of humor
earlier this month P her mom Kourtney
Kardashian and her younger brother rain
reenacted in AI parody of their former
reality show you should get the orange
soda it's amazing okay what would you
ladies like to drink orange soda please
I'll have the strawberry soda
and it clearly runs in the family
because P's cousin Northwest is also
down to clown around just watch her
lovingly imitate her mom Kim
Kardashian's most iconic lines hi I'm
Kim Kardashian West
[Music]
has a private Tick Tock account so we we
do lots of tick tocks together yeah
thankfully the veils since been lifted
so Kim and North can have all the fun on
their now public shared account
um
yeah because yeah I'm awake
you know what this is not funny you know
social media is such a great tool and
not to mention a great way to Goof Off
with the little ones
excuse me
you're excused
[Music]
foreign